식도의 12 지장경 검사 이짓 이라고도 하는 상부 위장관 내시경을 통해
의사는 상부 위장관의 안쪽 점막을 볼 수 있습니다
여기에는 식도와 위 십이지장에 포함됩니다
상부위장관 내시경은 고질적인 상복부 통증 메스꺼움 구토 출혈 삼키기
어려움 증상을 평가하는 데 이용됩니다
이 내시경 검사는 염증 과감히 엄 종양 궤양 등의 문제를 정확하게 탐지할
수 있습니다
검사는 끝에 조명과 소형 비디오 카메라가 달린
길고 얇으며 유연한 튜브 인 내시경을 사용하여 실시됩니다
이 카메라는 영상을 모니터로 전송합니다 내시경 검사를 하기 전에 정맥주사
가 시작되며 진통제와 진정제 가 제공될 것입니다
검사 중에 귀하의 혈압과 맥박 혈액 산소 수치가 모니터링 됩니다
의사는 귀하에 목에 스프레이를 뿌리거나 국부 마취제로 각을 하도록 하여
보게 감각을 둔화시키는 수 있습니다
기 왼쪽 측면으로 눕도록 안내 받게 됩니다 그리고 보조 마우스피스를 입에
끼우게 됩니다
일부의 경우 비강 캐뉼라 를 통해 산소를 보충 받을 수 있습니다
간단한 상부 내시경 검사는 10분에서 20분 가량이 소요됩니다
의사는 입을 통해 내시경을 부드럽게 삽입한 다음 천천히 조심스럽게 식도를
지나 위를 거쳐
12장 까지 이동 시키게 됩니다 검사 과정에서 어떤 통증 도 느껴지지
않습니다
의사는 점막을 평평하게 만들고 가시성을 높이기 위해 주기적으로 소량의
공기를 취 팔 수 있습니다
의사가 조직 표본을 채취하고 잔다면 검사 중에 내시경을 이용하여 한번
이상의 생체 검사를 함으로써 표본을 얻을 수 있습니다
생체 금산은 양성 조직과 암 조직을 9분하는데 도움이 됩니다 또한 궤양을
일으키는 박테리아 인 헬리코박터 파일로리 를 검출하기 위해서 도
이용됩니다
의사는 또한 내시경을 이용하여 궤양 치료 리나 협착 식도나 위의 좁아진
문제를 해결할 수 있습니다
검색 가 끝난 다음 귀한 은 마취가 풀릴 때까지 모니터링을 봤습니다
목이 아프고 부은 느낌을 받을 수 있습니다
검사가 끝난 후 귀가 시 이용할 교통수단을 미리 준비해야합니다